I think it's fair to say that we are
living in the I want to be a celebrity
era and even though there's nothing
wrong with it there's a way to do which
is the right way and there's a way to do
it which is the wrong way if you take
this route and people figure it out you
don't get a lot of good reputation here
so I want to make sure I teach you how
to be bulletproof on the way you build
your brand and you build your name and
for you to also know who is legit on
social media because look if there's
ever been a time where on social media
we've been naked it's today everybody
today is naked eight years ago you could
have bought some fake followers and fake
things and people would have gotten away
with and they would've said oh my gosh
this guy's got such a big followership
not today there are tools to catch
everyone today with fake accounts or
fake followership or any of that so so
almost located as if a thousand years
ago you and I a hundred years ago we
were going to a bank local bank were
gone with our horse a hundred years ago
to get a loan to buy a house and we go
to the bank and say hey we want to buy a
house and he says well how do I know you
make the payments
believe me I made all my payments how do
I know you're doing this and there's D
there's all this other stuff you can ask
the neighbors okay we'll give you
$50,000 $3,000 to buy a house whatever
the numbers back then they still didn't
know today you have a FICO score and
today you can't go to the bank and say
believe me I'll make the car payments
believe me I'll make the mortgage
payments they're not going to give it to
you they have ways of testing your
credibility with payments you make
that's called Experian TransUnion and
Equifax I believe right I'm going to
talk about those today with social media
following and this got started for us
the reason why Mario and I were talking
a lot of you said Pat should I buy
$8,000 program from this guy this guy's
selling me something for three grand
should i buy from him is this guy legit
he says he can help me take my account
to the next level this guy tells me he
can get me on TV this guy tells me can
give me the like I'm not here to audit
all those people for you I'm not here to
do that for you okay I am NOT a
consultant to sit and do this where I
run a financial firm but I will give you
direction on where to go for you to do
your own due diligence because at the
end of the day my goal is to develop you
into a leader into an independent
entrepreneur they can do this
without meeting every single time to
message me and say what do you think
about this company thing about that guy
so when we recently hit 100,000 YouTube
subs we started getting a lot of people
saying Pat can we do a product placement
on your channel can you please use this
product and talk about it and very
credible company's value we're not
talking like small companies doing a
million two million five million year
we're talking companies that have
products that they want us to talk about
and endorse an experience and how do I
feel about it if I like it talked about
it with my users and maybe give some way
and so we kind of took a step back and
we started getting people that want to
collaborate with us and especially now
with value taming I'm going to be
launching a lot of new collaborators to
up to you as the viewer unvalued came in
because some of the ladies are asking
Pat I want to see the perspective
entrepreneurship on the woman's side no
problem we're going to collaborate with
some ladies and bring it to you
some people said Pat I want to get to
the style part and this is why we teamed
up with Antonio Centeno from Wisconsin
who's got seven hundred fifty thousand
subs at this phone probably by the time
you watch it he's got a million he's got
a very very strong YouTube channel and a
company called real men real style so
when we first started looking at these
different teams that were reaching out
to us on YouTube it's a small community
of people who have 100,000 plus subs I
noticed everybody's kind of sizing each
other up those I'm not posturing but
it's kind of like is he legit is he not
legit and as we were going through this
everyone has access to the same tools
once we started going through this then
Antonio came here we spent 2-3 days
together we said wait a minute this
guy's legit we're legit we hit it off
and then by the time we're done we're
going to be doing such major projects
together you'll hear about this is going
to happen with many other names that
I'll give you as well
Kelly was here Kelly Nishimoto from
secure booty cute booty pants she makes
that Lexy Panterra wore that got 90
million views and she had a show
something borrowed something new the
host that I shall talk about with the
ladies side but we want to find out
who's real and who's not so I'm going to
talk about those tools with you six
years ago when we had no idea what we
were doing online we started a website
called Gauss Newton calm it was a
website dedicated to education bringing
education to folks around the world on
basic sub money it's still on by the way
go ask Newton
calm and we started reaching out to
other collapse other people to say why
don't you create content for our website
and talk about money these were
professional bloggers that were blogging
about money and I noticed one of the
messages we got back that mario's shared
with me I'll never forget the message he
said why would we create content for
your website when your website is ranked
16 million Alexa you know what 16
million is that means my own father's
not visiting my website that's what 60
million means he said why would I take
time to write an article for your blog
when my website is ranked 400 thousand
that message in itself told me everyone
knows what type of a product you have so
it made us take a step back and put a
very clear strategy together on what
type of a business and what type of a
brand we wanted to create to be
authentic to be real where you could say
I'm proud to be a follower of value Tim
and call yourself a value tenor because
you know if you come here the content
we're going to share with you is going
to be legit so let's get right into it
by the way how to like my artwork this
is my snapchat which looks nothing like
snapchat buzz the best I could do if you
you message me on snapchat with big
David 19 always get back to people on
snapchat this is my Twitter I'll do it's
a little heavy-duty Twitter and you
should go on a diet and an Instagram I
think I do a pretty good job on YouTube
here so let's start off with twitter
twitter twitter is the easiest one to go
through so twitter is famous for a
couple things one of the things twitter
is famous for its famous for having the
most fake followers on the website it is
number one for the most fake accounts
out of all the social media platforms
this is one of the reasons why people
still haven't bought twitter - it has
been on the market for a while a lot of
people said that we're going to buy no
one's yet about it they're not
interested in because there's way way
too many fake accounts on Twitter so
what do you do with Twitter you
following people on Twitter and you know
I have 200,000 followers on Twitter I
have 300,000 followers on Twitter man
that's crazy how do I know if they're
real there's a website called Twitter
audit com which I put a link on the
bottom of my website if you watching
this on youtube you come to my website
you'll see Twitter audit dot-com you
click on Twitter audit and test it out
test it out with somebody that you're
follow and put their name on there I
will guarantee you you will be
shell-shocked on
how many of their followers are real or
not rule of thumb is anything above 60
70 80 percent is solid anything below 50
percent they're overly but some a fake
Twitter account followers and if
anything below 15 to 10 percent it's
just it's it's they're trying to wait
too hard you know it's like they're it's
like a boy back in school that was
afraid to walk around and and he would
put some socks in his underwear to make
himself look like he was a little bit
stronger than he really was listen for
those of you that my fake Twitter
followers you're putting socks take the
socks out and just man up and maybe
don't wear spandex would be your safest
bet on what to do but the reality part
of it is today everyone knows if you're
using a sock or not everybody so go to
twitter.com and test it out test your
own account as manikanta some other
people's account test some social media
followers some people in your company
maybe some executives and you will
realize how legitimate and how legit
it's not for some but you need to know
who's doing it the proper way Twitter
you know you can see if someone's
Twitter followers are fake if you just
follow it and you take a look at it
you'll see they're following nine
hundred people but they only have 18
followers back that's a fake account and
if there's too many like that it's a
trend they bought they bought fake
followers there's a guy the other day
who one of his executives and his
company reached out to me and he said
hey you know this guy in the company
he's saying that he got more followers
in one day then you've had your entire
career and you know he's chilling on
social media and I just told him I said
listen man how many followers at 65,000
and one day and you only have 60 4900
Twitter followers I said first of all
congratulations to second did you have
you ran a Twitter audit yet on him and
he says what do you mean I said why
don't you go on to and on the computer I
suppose would deduct Elizabeth he goes
on Twitter odd I said put his name on
there he puts his name on that I said
how many do you see that are real two
percent were real he was silent I said I
test yours out he tested his out then he
went another person and another says
well these are real I said yes because
it's very easy for Twitter to track
nowadays who's fake and who's not
because their investors are requiring
them to know who is real and not all
these fake people
people are now tracking he backed up as
I apologized so much such-and-such and I
said look you know Twitter is not a
platform that works very well for us
some people do very well on Twitter some
people don't do very well on to it which
I'm gonna highlight on that at the end
on what you should do with your own
brand but but just to know when some
people are putting the fake stuff out
there you gotta read between the BS that
everybody wants to be a celebrity and
this is I know announced a podcast and
everyone's following me now listen it
doesn't work that way social media to
build a brand is a five year game plan
it's not something you do in six months
or three months or put one video in your
celebrity I wish it was that way it
doesn't work that way if it was that way
everybody would be well-known and
everybody would have millions of subs on
YouTube but there's there's work that
goes behind it right so that's that part
here with Twitter to keep in mind so
there's websites out there many websites
if you just go on google and type and
buy Twitter followers by Twitter
followers okay and also I have one here
I don't want to give them credit because
I don't want to endorse this habit this
is one that Mario and them pulled up you
can buy a thousand followers for seven
bucks you can buy 50,000 followers 130
bucks you can buy a million followers
for one thousand two hundred and
ninety-nine dollars and under it says
real followers what they mean by real
followers is there are people all day
that create these accounts that follow
people that are really set up by real
human beings that's been set up and then
they have a bot that goes and follows
you and it takes one week for you to get
a million followers and you pay twelve
hundred ninety-nine dollars for that it
does very well it's almost like those
credit repair guys then know how to
boost your credit score for one week
when you're trying to get the loan and
it goes back to $4.99 that's kind of
what it is except here everyone knows
you have fake followers today with
Twitter adhikam so just know the
difference and follow the authentic
people on social media who are actually
making an effort to do it the right way
there's plenty of them out there that
are doing it the right way
and then if you do it right and you're
bringing value you're not trying to you
know con people and all that stuff
eventually we'll get a lot of proper
followers next let's talk about YouTube
YouTube is a little bit different let me
tell you why YouTube's a little bit
different they don't play YouTube does
not play so if you try to play games
with YouTube they will simply
shut down your account when I tell you
they'll shut down your account they will
shut down your account especially if you
try to monetize it so there's a lot of
same things you can go put by YouTube
views if you go and buy YouTube views we
are verified account with YouTube so we
are we work with creators studios for
YouTube there they have the Creator our
YouTube creators I think it's called
where you go and once you're part of a
group and I think we just participate in
their silver because we got over a
hundred thousand subs so you get support
to get all this other stuff and then you
don't want to be flagged if your flag
you lose your opportunity so you can
check to see which brands are flagged or
not here's here's a few simple rules
that I follow with YouTube channels if
the YouTube channel has chosen to hide
their subscribers and comments I'm
concerned I don't do any business with
anybody if their YouTube channel is
hidden with subscribers and comments
here's why here's why our comments are
wide open many years ago we have to make
a decision three years ago whether we
leave it open we keep it private I said
why keep it private
now what if somebody says something bad
about you what if they do we're not
trying to get everybody in the world to
like us we're trying to make sure we do
our part we bring value to if you like
it you stick around if you don't go to
another place work it with that it's
competition and you make us keep getting
better and we have to get your attention
and I'm creating content that I believe
pound-for-pound we can't go against
anybody that's why you keep coming back
that's my job right and we're gonna do
it I don't know how long I'm gonna keep
creating content for I may go three more
months six more months twelve more
months but I'm still creating content on
YouTube right so anytime I see YouTube
channel that's hidden it subs or hidden
it's comments I don't do any business
with them by the way the other day Kip
called me
they keep that with you do you remember
what is his name was the kid that was
here who did the interview he flew in
and did an interview brought a camera
guy and his YouTube channel had 1400
subs
okay but I liked him and I said no
problem I'll give you an hour interview
he did the interview Akshay was a very
good enemy has a lot of good questions I
said ok to him and I told Mario no
problem why because he was authentic he
was real he was transparent he was open
and you could tell he's not really
killing it but I loved the fact that he
doesn't have a problem saying look I'm
really trying that's
to me I want to do business with people
like that and believe it or not the
players at the top on YouTube they're
not lightweights they can read
everything they know every single thing
they're the same exact way as well so
don't worry if you don't have any of
that stuff going on here's another thing
look at ratios what do I mean by ratios
if some if you look at a video that's
got a hundred thousand views but it's
only got 49 likes they bought views if
the videos got a hundred thousand views
but it's only got 50 comments they
bought views okay it's not possible
those ratios don't make sense you got to
pay attention to that on how that works
out I'll give you two tools for you to
balk if you want to for YouTube it's
called socialblade.com social blade is
unbelievable I believe it's a number one
tool for anybody that's wanting to
verify their YouTube channels or you
have your own YouTube channel social
blade is number one because it tells you
you can literally pick 3 different
channels like yourself and 2 other
channels and size yourself up against
different channels and find out how many
subs you're getting per day and how many
views you're getting per day and how
many minutes you're getting per day
versus your competitors and they'll
literally put the whole chart together
for you for free social blade phenomenal
you can go and look at some subs and
again I'll run this and some companies
doesn't come up because they made it
private I don't do any business it's
shut down for me I don't feel that
company's being transparent or that
individuals being transparent and
anytime somebody is trying to be too
secretive about the public time nowadays
look we don't need to do business that's
the way I do but you know you can choose
to do business with that I choose not to
do business with that if I'm gonna do
business with you I need to know exactly
where you stand with your content you're
creating social blade you will fall in
love with again if you get on there and
by the way you know YouTube has certain
termination guidelines on what they
terminate their YouTube channels for
Dennis let's put the link to that as
well on the bottom on the website you'll
see here termination guidelines for
YouTube YouTube is a professional
company they ran by they're owned by
Google and they're very very
professional when you do business with
them no one's perfect but we like doing
business with them as well and then
obviously YouTube there's plenty just
would buy YouTube use tons of website
will come up down I'm not going to give
you too much credit to this next one
here now let's go to website I have a
lot of people that will say things like
why I have thousands of
well every day that come on my website
and visit my website and I'm like wow
that's impressive and then you go on
alexa.com and it shows your website is
ranked 13 million people you know how
many people visit a website if it's
ranked 13 million people one to five a
day and one of them is themselves so you
just got to keep that in mind
so you can't just say I get pins of
thousands of people that visit my
website and I get so many questions and
requests it's just not possible
amateurs will buy into it it's like you
it's like it almost like a 40 year old
man trying to fool a 18 year old girl
how amazing you are you're not going to
fool a 33 year old woman it's just not
going to happen and some people that are
in the social media side that I kind of
their questionable on their approach and
who they pray there it's like a pray on
who they're trying to get money out of
these 18 year old people to give them
eight thousand dollars five thousand
dollars it's I have a very difficult
time with that way of doing business I
like sleeping on a soft pillow I really
like a soft pillow I like to sleep
within a half a second when I lay down
and if I take money from that 18 19 year
old kid yes he may pay me ten grand but
do I really want to have him go to his
mom dad for credit cards I don't want to
be doing that I don't want to be doing I
don't recommend you doing anything you
don't need to build your brand or your
business that way to get big believe me
there's a lot of people that are doing
the right way so LexA alexa.com
will tell you websites ranking believe
me we we have our team that gets the
reports all the time we size ourselves
up on where we're at to grow our
business we have certain other people
that we can compete ourselves with to
grow our business to the next level but
there's a website out there called
weekly M comm weekly the letter M com I
have a link on the bottom that takes you
exactly to where you can put the rank of
a website and it tells you exactly how
many visitors they get monthly so I'll
tell you if you're ranked 10 million it
means you get maybe one visitor a day if
you're ranked 1 million you're getting
1500 visitors per month if you ranked a
hundred thousand it means you're getting
thirty thousand visitors per month and
you can go down and you'll see all the
other numbers on them it's a very good
tool to use it's not Alexa it's actually
weekly M that gives you the Alexa
numbers on there so now let's go to
Instagram one of the things I like that
Instagram did in 2014 they called
Instagram purged because as much as
Twitter had a lot of fake accounts and
and one of the reasons I believe Twitter
is not getting bought out is because
they're not willing to purge their
accounts they need to purge all the fake
accounts today today twitter jack look
at me jack purged those accounts today
when they purged their accounts they
were bought like this you got to purge
those accounts even if some of these
numbers get very very small
you got to purge all those accounts okay
so Instagram in 2014 said no we're doing
a perch it's like doing an audit mixing
you know somebody with a hundred
thousand uh uh Instagram followers went
all the way down to eighteen thousand
followers why there was eighty two
thousand fake followers now there was a
lot of fake bots back in the days with
Instagram that everybody took a hit on
that you it wasn't just you everybody
porn and all this other stuff so
Instagram had to clean that up Twitter
still has that they haven't cleaned it
up because the numbers look at they need
to get rid of that and just man up and
woman up and make sure everybody knows
this and we're transferring this is who
we are they did that their valuation
would go people would actually look at
them and trust them Instagram did that
and next thing you know everybody
started saying wow I can't fake
Instagram anymore and I think they're
going to do a purge again and sometimes
this you I think they did smaller but
not a bigger one it's coming up now
instagram has a lot of bots that people
use some of them are effective but so
for the most part with Instagram just if
there's way too much fake stuff that's
out there again I don't recommend it
it's not only effect it's not effective
to you know it doesn't work anymore with
Instagram they did a very smart thing
they're owned by Facebook so Facebook
doesn't play around you know you try to
do something fake with Facebook they
can't you they're not a big fan of it
Facebook has the same thing you can buy
fake fans and all that other stuff
believe me there's so many things you
can do with Facebook as well on the fake
side you'll see some Facebook fan pages
that have a million fans and you're like
wow this Facebook fan page has million
likes but every time they post a picture
three likes two likes
one like eight like seven likes how come
you have them not good ratios and you
got some guys that are doing a very good
job and they're advertising a lot no
problem you got advertising use some
resources to get your name out there you
can always that's a right way of doing
it
you can do that and Facebook's pretty
good if you do that part of it with them
podcasters a lot of great podcasters out
there John Lee Dumas is one of the best
podcasters entrepreneur on fire I was on
John Lee Dumas entrepreneurial fire late
recently and he's one the best I believe
it's not the best podcast for
entrepreneurs out there he's got
millions of downloads that people have
and you can always check people as well
on podcasts and there's a website called
pod track with a C P o d TR AC com I'm
gonna put that link on the bottom as
well for you to check do your part you
know don't just fall onto uh sell this
was great you know do your own study do
your own research and and support people
that are doing it the right way and if
you're trying to create your own brand
do it the right way believe me people
are not dumb people know what's going on
people are a lot more educated
especially if you want the real quality
following they kind of know what's going
on the last but not least snapchat
snapchat you can't buy anything you know
why because no one knows anyone's
numbers anyways so who cares
so one good thing about snapchat there's
nobody selling anything to figure buy
some new friends or but nothing no one
cares no one knows you have no idea how
many followers celebrities have you have
no idea how many views there but you no
one has any idea okay so they've made
themselves private for a long time and
they're doing a pretty good job they're
figuring out ways to improve although
they're struggling a little bit with ads
but I have a feeling they're going to
figure it out because they're doing it
the right way these guys need a miracle
I'm thinking about doing a video for
Twitter a message directly to Jack to
Jack for us to share this video with
everybody I'm gonna have a meeting with
Jack to tell him exactly I love Twitter
but I hate what they're doing I almost
feel like for the people that are social
media people man we got to fix this
thing and make sure it sticks around so
who knows I'm not sold yet what I'll do
the video or not what stay tuned maybe
it'll come out here pretty soon on what
we can do to save Twitter from not going
to be in my space that's prime maybe
that's the title by the way right to
prevent how to prevent Twitter from
being myspace that's that's not a bad
title Dennis what do you think I like
that so again look I did all this stuff
for you because many of you asked who to
follow who not to follow just use these
tools to check it for yourself who's
real nor not and eventually don't try to
be dominant on all of them I'm not
myself you know for
Twitter I only have sixty four thousand
nine hundred followers and we have to
try so many creative ways to get
followers to search keywords and
entrepreneur and all that's a lot of
work we hired people but Twitter is good
but it's not great for us Instagram is
okay for us Instagram is very good this
morning I was with my personal trainer
who's a bodybuilder he's a professional
bodybuilding he's six one to 85 so just
try to figure this out six one to 85 and
I said Instagram they do well on
Instagram because it's all physique look
pictures image that works okay but a
message may be a little bit different
snapchat you to figure out what works
for you and make that your main play
some people say I can be good on all of
them look just like in sports you
remember when kids were athletic
remember some kids that were very good
in all sports like I can play my son can
pretty much play any sport but if you
want your kid to be great he's got to
pick one sports to pick one of these and
make it your best platform yet be
adaptable in case something crazy
happens like Jack's not preparing
Twitter then you know how to make your
own audibles as well so with that being
said then it's let me get my favorite
pillow we are making some rearrangements
on our goals we've been saying October
by June 1st of 2008 it's June 30th of
2017 will be accordingly in subs
we're going to get there way before
we're going to make a little bit of an
audacious goal we believe we'll get 2
million subs before the end of 2017
because we plan on taking this channel
to complete different level I'm talking
to complete wait till you see the
projects and the individuals and
collaborators we're going to bring to
you for you to know when you think about
the word entrepreneur and you want to go
to one stop to have any of your
questions answered for free you're going
to come to value Tammy you'll see why so
if you haven't seen more than one video
please subscribe and watch some of the
other videos and try a south and if you
got any questions comments or thoughts
about today's video comment on the
bottom and if you watch this video on a
complete different website you can
always come back to Patrick Betty be
calm boom and you get all the content on
there taking everybody bye-bye
you